Du klären, die Leute beschweren sich immer über unsere Audioqualität.
Hast du auch Probleme mit unserer Audioqualität?
Das ist ja eigentlich in Ordnung, oder?
Ich kenne das problemlos.
Also ich weiß nicht, wo hast du alle habt.
Das ist doch gerade...
Ganz im Ernst.
Also ich lege hier das Telefon, lege ich da hinten auf den Tisch.
Und wir reden ja laut genug.
Und eigentlich müsste...
Wir sitzen in der anderen Ecke vom Raum.
Ich denke, das ist ja tadellos.
Tipptopp, tipptopp.
Und du hast ja durch die harten Wände hier rundherum noch so ein bisschen Halt.
Ich muss sagen, es gibt eigentlich nur noch mehr Abnuch.
So ein bisschen was nimmt die Couch in der Ecke da hinten raus.
Ich finde, das sollten alle Podcasts so machen.
Das klingt einfach natürlicher.
Wie so Amateur-Porn.
Das ist so der Klang, den die Flieger an der Wand
auch hätte.
Ja, wir machen jetzt trotzdem mal was anders, oder?
Ja, können wir mal ausprobieren.
Mach mal Quali mal an.
Okay, Quali, mach mal an.
In 3, 2, 1.
Hi, Kenan.
Boah, Henrik, du klingst ganz anders.
Ja, Akronomisierbar, Folge 13.
13 sind wir schon.
Okay, krass.
Wir sind fast strafmündig.
Darf ich dieses Bier jetzt schon trinken?
Das darf ich erst ab Folge 18 trinken dann, oder was?
Nee, 16 in Deutschland.
In ein paar Folgen dürfen wir unser Bier wirklich legal trinken.
Aber Alkohopops darf man erst ab Folge 18 trinken.
Aber das eine, was ich tatsächlich
laut Alterstechnik machen darf,
worauf ich tatsächlich recht stolz bin,
also nicht, dass ich irgendwie auf mein Alter stolz sein kann,
weil das schreitet ja so oder so voran,
muss ich ja nicht viel machen, außer überleben,
ich darf jetzt Autos mieten, ohne
einen Scheißaufpreis zu zahlen.
Du bist über 25. Ja.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Aber trotzdem, habe ich letztens
erstmalig in Anspruch nehmen können.
Ich glaube, als ich das letzte Mal in den USA war,
da war ich noch 24,
habe mir ein Auto gemietet und ich musste,
wenn ich fahre, also wenn jeden Tag
Ich dachte, man darf überhaupt nicht unter 25.
Nee, das darf schon, aber ich musste für jeden Tag
25 Dollar Auftrag zahlen.
Alter Fall. Und weil wir das Auto zwei Wochen hatten,
war das halt schon nicht gerade wenig Geld.
war total bescheuert.
Ja, damit sich unter 25
Jahrhundert noch kein Auto haben, nicht einfach mal eins mieten
und dann irgendwelchen Scheiß bauen.
Die Versicherung ist wahrscheinlich teurer.
Das wird dann einfach an den Kunden
weitergeleitet oder sowas.
Meine lustigste Story
mit einer Autovermietung war meine Schwester,
die mit Freunden nach Rotterdam
zu Silvester fahren wollte.
Schneesturmwetter vor ein paar Jahren.
Und sie hatten halt bei Sixt
sich ein Auto gemietet, kleinstmögliches,
billigstmögliches und VW Polo wollten sie haben.
zu Fürth,
haben das Ding gemietet, hingefahren,
die bei 6 Jahren, wir haben gerade so ein bisschen Schneesturm,
ein paar Probleme, unsere Autos herzukriegen.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt
leider kein VW Polo oder vergleichbares
Auto für euch. Wir haben hier diese
S-Klasse für...
Das Ding war irgendwie
mehr als 100.000...
Der Economy Class ist leider kein Platz mehr,
nach da vorne.
Irgendwie mehr als 100.000 Euro wert.
Und meine Schwester ist...
Ich möchte jetzt nicht meine Schwester als naiven Menschen verkaufen,
aber zu... Ja, ne, Versicherung dafür will ich auch
zahlen. Ist ja bloß Schneesturm draußen.
Wir fahren ja jetzt nach Rotterdam mit
einer unversicherten S-Klasse.
Das ist total bescheuert.
Nichts passiert. Aber, oh mein Gott.
Wäre die Versicherung so
teuer gewesen? Die Versicherung hätten sie
mehr zahlen müssen als für den VW Polo. Das haben sie
dann nicht direkt mit aufgestockt, quasi aus dem
Bestellung. Für die Versicherung von dem VW Polo?
Also die haben nicht die Versicherung von dem
VW Polo bekommen für die S-Klasse,
sondern eine andere. Details kenne ich
leider nicht. Dass sie überhaupt unversichert ein Auto
rausgeben. Aber na gut, okay, du musst sie am 2x2
nicht ohne Versicherung, aber halt
die Mindeststufe, das was
dabei ist, wo du dann halt eine richtig krasse Selbstbeteiligung hast.
Oh Mann. Von sehr viel Geld.
Das ist echt bedeutet.
Bei Schneesturmwetter.
Fährst du quer durch Deutschland,
nicht nur Deutschland, sondern quer durch Europa.
Geil.
Ja, okay.
Warum nicht?
Ja, die vier Feinde der deutschen Autovermietung.
Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter.
Das sind hier die deutschen Bahnen, die davon betroffen sind.
Auch mit.
Und bist du gut reingerutscht ins neue Jahr?
Klar, du auch?
Ja, ich habe total entspannt gefeiert.
Schön.
Ich wohne ja relativ weit oben in Dresden
und habe dann auch noch eine Dachwohnung
und habe dann einfach irgendwie Kuppel drüben gehabt
und wir haben ein paar Bier getrunken
und dann auf den Fenster geguckt.
Ja, finde ich auch ganz schön.
Das haben wir nicht anders gemacht dieses Jahr.
Wir waren zu viert, haben Raclette gegessen
und niemand ist vor die Tür gegangen.
Raclette ist so ein bisschen wie Truthahn, oder?
Das ist so etwas, was so eine Eimer im Jahr isst.
Das war auch so krass, ich gehe am Vorabend zum Bäcker,
ja, haben sie noch Baguettes da?
Nee, die sind heute alle ausverkauft, wir haben schon extra viel bestellt.
Ja, das ist so dieser eine Tag im Jahr, wo jeder fucking Baguette haben möchte, oder was?
Die Franzosen so, hä, warum?
Sind ihr zu Hause geblieben die ganze Zeit?
Aber es ging ja auch dieses Jahr auf Twitter unglaublich viele schöne Aufnahmen rum
von der Feinstaubbelastung,
die durch das Feuerwerk
zustande kommt.
Es ist unglaublich, was das für eine Umweltverschmutzung ist.
Unglaublich.
Boah.
Es wandert so in einer Welle,
in so einer Feinstaubverschmutzungs-Laola
um die Erde einmal drum herum, einmal pro Stunde
in der nächsten Zeitzone.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass es so einheitlich ist.
Bzw. würde mich mal interessieren,
wo überall Feuerwerk gefeuert wird.
Silvester, USA zum Beispiel, ja nicht so.
Eigentlich ist es auch in anderen Ländern
in Europa gar nicht so häufig.
Ein Kumpel von mir war in England und hat sich dann
beschwert, dass es da fast überhaupt kein Feuerwerk
gab. Und auch in Deutschland ist es ja auch bloß
an Silvester tatsächlich erlaubt.
Heute hat
jemand vor meinem Fenster eine Rakete getündet.
Das hält
die gerade jetzt nicht davon ab.
Ja klar, den findet ja auch keiner.
Ich meine, wir sind in Dresden, hier gibt es alle zwei Wochen
an der Elbe irgendein offizielles Feuerwerk.
Ja, aber du darfst es nur ein paar Tage
vor Silvester kaufen.
Achso, also wirklich als Privatperson ist
gibt es diverse Regelungen. Das wundert mich nicht, aber das freut
mich auch, dass es zumindest da ein paar Regelungen gibt.
Also wir waren nach Mitternacht noch mal rausgegangen,
sind hier um der Ecke
zu deiner alten WG, zu einer
Party gegangen und selbst
hier in dem Wohngebiet hier, ich bin
ja zu Silvestre überhaupt nicht gerne draußen, das hat für mich
irgendwie was Kriegsartiges. Ja, das ist schrecklich.
Auf dem Hinweg
hat es halt links und rechts geböllert und auf dem Rückweg
habe ich zum ersten Mal gesehen, wie ein
Auto, was da lang war, voll mit
dem Reifen eine komplette
Sektflasche überfahren hat. Das hat auch ein geiles
Geräusch gemacht. Ich habe einmal
den Fehler gemacht und bin nach München
gefahren zu Silvestre mit ein paar Freunden.
Da waren wir direkt am Marienplatz um 0 Uhr.
Und also erstmal der Marienplatz
komplett voll mit Menschen. Und so
5 vor 12 ungefähr spaltet sich das
komplett in zwei Lager auf, die an dem Rand
vom Marienplatz stehen. Und die Leute, also
anscheinend ist das so eine Tradition, die da
abgefeuerten wird. Das ist total krank.
Da gibt es Leute mit so Regenschirmen, die den so nach
vorne halten und dann werden zwischen den
Regenschirmen durch ja wirklich so artilleriemäßig
beschießen sich dann beide Seiten
gegenseitig mit Raketen. Es fliegt wenig in die Luft hoch,
sondern mehr so auf die andere Seite. Total
krank. Seid ihr bekloppt? Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Leute
da sich ernsthafte Verletzungen zuziehen.
Da haben wir uns dann schnell zurückgezogen. Das war
sehr unerwartet. Aus dem Ort, wo ich herkomme,
da haben wir
manchmal vor dem Theater auch gefeiert. Das ist ja häufig auch
so ein Platz, wo Leute feiern. Da geht meine Onkel, meine Tante
jedes Jahr hin. Ich denke mir immer, seid ihr bescheuert?
Und da hast du
regelmäßig links und rechts irgendwelche Schlägereien.
und Leute, die verletzt werden.
Und das habe ich am nächsten mitbekommen, als ich
Zivi war, da war nämlich mein letzter Zivitag, der 31.12.
Und ich war beim Roten Kreuz
und meine Kollegen habe ich die verabschiedet.
Und dann sind die dann schon mit dem Tross los
mit zwei RTWs,
also Rettungswagen, und haben sich einfach da an dem Platz
neben dem Theater schon mal platziert,
um quasi so ein Lazarett aufzubauen,
um die ganzen Verletzten da einzusammeln.
Das ist schon krass, was so
Silvestermäßig jedes Jahr abgeht.
Also ich hoffe, ihr Hörer seid auch alle
einigermaßen heil über das neue Jahr
gekommen und habt nicht irgendwelche
Böller abbekommen oder euch Kliebmaßen
weggesprengt oder anderweitig.
Ja, würde ich es natürlich auch niemandem
den Spaß nehmen, wenn das für euch dazugehört, ein bisschen zu
böllern, solange ihr es sicher macht.
Ich dachte, sich Sachen wegzuspringen.
Nein, hoffentlich nicht. Also ich hoffe nicht, dass das jemand
seine Tradition ist.
Das ist zumindest keine Tradition, die du lange
durchhältst. Hat so eine begrenzte Anzahl,
weißt du, die man sich wegspringen kann.
Genau. Und ansonsten habe ich noch, ist noch
meine klassische Tradition, dass ich mich zu Silvester
Leuten austausche, die nicht
auf dem Kongress waren und mir von denen erzählen
lassen, was es alles für coole Talks gab,
die ich alle nicht mitbekommen habe, weil
ich auf dem Kongress war und die Talks deswegen nicht gucken konnte.
Hast du, wir haben ja unsere letzte Folge
am zweiten Tag vom
Kongress aufgezeichnet, da waren
ja noch Vorträge danach. Hast du noch ein paar
coole Sachen mitbekommen? Ich meine, ich habe
seitdem es geschafft, ein oder
zwei Talks zu schauen,
aber muss gerade auch passen, welche
das tatsächlich gewesen sind. Aber Sachen, wo du live
dabei warst, die erst waren, nachdem wir unsere
aufgenommen haben?
Achso.
Huch, klar. Natürlich haben wir ja noch ein paar Sachen.
Genau, erzähl mal was.
Achso, zum Beispiel, was lief denn nach uns?
Minkorrekt war doch noch auf der Bühne.
Oh, die großen Podcaster.
Sind die ja seit drei, vier Jahren, glaube ich,
machen die ja jetzt Live-Aufnahme auf dem Kongress.
Das ist jetzt das...
Das dritte Mal?
Das vierte Mal tatsächlich.
Das erste Jahr war auf dem Sendezentrum.
Da waren sie ganz klein.
Das zweite Jahr war das erste Mal,
wo sie nicht in Saal 1 durften.
Da saß ich drin, das war absolut Bombe.
Das zweite Jahr haben sie das
gleiche nochmal versucht, genauso.
Dorften sie auch nicht in Saal 1.
War ich auch so ein Ticker täuscht.
Letztes Jahr,
beim 33er-Weise quasi dasselbe
nochmal gemacht haben und da hatten sie nicht ganz so geile Experimente.
Und dieses Jahr haben sie sich ja mal ein bisschen
an den Ig Nobelpreisen
entlang gehangelt. Die waren mir schon
relativ geläufig, weil ich auch immer
auf Science Friday
die Zusammenfassung, beziehungsweise Science Friday strahlt
einfach die gesamte
Preisverleihung aus. Also von der tatsächlichen
Verleihung wusste ich nicht, wie die vonstatten geht.
Ich wusste natürlich, dass der Gigabelpreis existiert und was
da so gibt an den lustigen Sachen. Also dieses kleine Mädchen,
was dann manchmal auf die Bühne kommt und dann sagt,
please stop, I'm bored.
Please stop, I'm bored.
Die habe ich noch nie gesehen. Ich kannte das
immer bloß alles aus Audio. Aber daran haben sie
sich so ein bisschen lang gehandelt und es war eine ziemlich coole Show.
Und das Schönste war eigentlich das allerletzte Experiment,
was sie gemacht haben. Dann kam sie nochmal auf die Bühne und haben gesagt,
so das ist das nächste Experiment.
Da bin ich jetzt sehr aufgeregt und es könnte
fürchterlich schief gehen.
deswegen machen wir das jetzt so als Nachtrag,
dann können wir das im Zweifelsfall, falls es scheitert, einfach wegschauen.
Ich fand, also
ich habe es echt nicht kommen sehen, auch als er schon
so ein bisschen vorbereitet war. Jetzt müssen wir es doch sagen, oder?
Also wenn jetzt nicht gespoert werden wollen,
dann springt einfach mal so, keine Ahnung, zwei Minuten in die Zukunft
und hört darüber weg.
Also Reinhard hatte
auf der Bühne gestanden und hat, wie gesagt,
dieses letzte Experiment angekündigt, dass es sehr wohl auch in die Hose hätte
gehen können, wie er meinte. Ich hatte keine Ahnung, von was er
jetzt spricht, irgendwas Krasses,
was hier nicht
gefährlich ist, aber was halt nicht
sehr sicher funktioniert.
Und dann zeigt er plötzlich so Bilder
von der ominösen Frau,
seine Freundin, und stellt sie so ein bisschen vor.
Also krass, so hat die ominöse Frau jetzt mit Bild
im Stream hier, das ist ja
voll krass gezeigt, wer das
so ist. Und dann geht er so ein bisschen
weiter, peinliche Fotos von ihr zeigen
und dann führt sie selber zum Ausgleich.
Und dann dämmert es einem schon so ein bisschen,
worauf das jetzt hinausläuft, aber hat es schon ein bisschen
vergessen, dass er so ein Experiment angekündigt hat.
Aber dann macht er ihr live auf der Bühne
einen Antrag.
Das war super süß.
Ich fand es wirklich super, super toll.
Das war super schön.
Wie gesagt, vorher nicht kommen sie in den Ausfahrt.
Es war echt schön.
Ich habe noch nie so einen Moment gehabt.
Ich bin noch nicht so in Kreisen, wo ich sowas erwarte.
Ich war auch einen Tick peinlich berührt,
weil ich mir dachte, hätten die das nicht vielleicht.
Aber gut, okay, er hat sich selber ausgesucht,
das auf der Bühne zu machen.
Und da waren halt 4000 Leute dabei.
Aber es war schon schön,
dabei gewesen zu sein.
Vielleicht machen wir ja irgendwann unsere 100. Sendung akronomisierbar auf der Bühne.
Dann machst du den Antrag, weißt du?
Dann mache ich dir einen Antrag.
Ein Katsch.
Okay.
Ich war noch in ein paar anderen Kryptovorträgen,
oder sehr technischen Vorträgen, die ich auch überaus spannend fand.
Was gab es denn da so?
Der eine war in dem kleinsten Saal, The Noise Protocol Framework.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Framework, das Neues-Protokoll-Framework.
Derjenige, der einen Vortrag gehalten hat, hat festgestellt,
die Leute, die sich so TLS oder SSL oder an unterschiedliche Handshake-Verfahren ausdenken,
die fangen an die Mob wieder bei Null an.
Und dieses Neues-Protokoll-Framework ist quasi einfach ein Framework,
um Kryptoprotokolle zu bootstrappen.
Und was dabei rauskommt, ist, du triffst ja immer wieder die gleichen Entscheidungen.
Welches Hash-Verfahren nehme ich? Welches Krypto-Verfahren nehme ich?
Wie sieht mein Handshake aus?
über wie viele Sachen garantiert mir der
der Helm und Handshake, den ich dann mache.
Und das kannst du, wenn du dein
Protokoll mit diesem Framework beschreibst,
kommt zum Schluss wie so ein Compiled Triple,
sowas wie
Unknown Unknown Wasm
oder wie heißt es?
macOS X64
Darwin oder sowas.
Gibt es hier einen Triple,
der quasi dein gesamtes Krypto-Protokoll
beschreibt, mit welchem Hash-Verfahren
und welchem Krypto-Verfahren
und welchem Handshake-Verfahren.
Das fand ich eigentlich ziemlich spannend,
einfach weil es auch immer ein bisschen aufgebrochen hat,
was gehört denn jetzt zum Design von einem Krypto-Verfahren dazu
und warum ist es sinnvoll, da mal einen Schritt weiter nach oben zu gehen,
metamäßig darüber nachzudenken, was wiederholt sich da
und was kann man da vielleicht wiederverwenden.
Und interessanterweise wurde in dem Vortrag auch erwähnt,
ach, das ist übrigens auch das, was WhatsApp macht.
Und das hat mich so ein bisschen geflasht,
dass auf so einem Krypto-Talk, auf einem Kongress quasi WhatsApp als Beispiel genimmt,
und zwar als Positiv-Beispiel.
Ja, WhatsApp ist ja so ein bisschen das Signal von Signal, was nicht Signal ist.
Boah, was?
Die Signal-Leute, die Open-Wars-Passistence-Leute, nicht die Signal-Leute,
haben ja einen eigenen Client geschrieben, Signal für ihre Krypto,
um zu zeigen, was das Protokoll so kann und wie man es benutzen kann.
Aber Signal nutzt ja quasi niemand.
Also sehr viele Leute, die ich kenne und die wir kennen, aber sonst niemand auf die Welt bezogen.
Und WhatsApp ist ja ein ultra verbreiteter Chat-Client.
Gehört halt bündnerweise der falschen Firma.
Aber ist ja unglaublich verbreitet.
Ist auch technisch gesehen super komisch.
Also gerade dieser Desktop-Client, der alles durch dein Mobilgerät tunnelt.
Also quasi, dass es wirklich nur ein Gerät gibt, was für dich Nachrichten verschickt und empfängt.
Naja, das hängt auch mit der Krypto zusammen.
Ja, aber das musst du doch nicht so machen.
Das kann man auch sinnvoller lösen.
Du musst quasi rückwirkend auf die ganzen Nachrichten zugreifen.
Du machst einen Krypto-Channel mit deinem Telefon auf
und dann spricht der Desktop-Client nur mit dem Telefon,
also der Web-Client, soweit ich weiß,
ohne über den Server zu gehen, direkt mit dem Telefon.
Und auf die Art und Weise komprometrierst du halt deine Krypto nicht,
wenn du nochmal so eine Web-Anwendung zur Verfügung stellst.
Ja, also okay, so kannst du es machen, das sehe ich ein,
aber so musst du es ja nicht machen.
Wire zum Beispiel nutzt auch dieses selbe Protokoll.
Ja, bei Wire hast du dann, wenn du einen Client nachträglich hinzufügst,
siehst du, aus Privacy-Gründen können wir
dir die Nachrichten zurückwirken,
so und so weit nicht mehr anzeigen.
Du kannst doch trotzdem dein Rekeying von deinem mobilen Client anfordern,
dass der einfach die ganze History
nochmal neu keyed mit dem
Key von dem Desktop-Client. Also wir sehen auch hier Evolution
von, wahrscheinlich bräuchte man mal ein Meta-Framework
für, wie baue ich einen Kryptomessenger,
mit den ganzen Sachen, also einer Checkliste,
die man aufbauen müsste, aber wir reden schon wieder über Messenger.
Scheiße.
An der Stelle habe ich allerdings
vorgeistern ein paar interessante News mitbekommen,
es ist wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo wir das hier veröffentlichen, auch schon ein alter Hut, aber
die Whisper System Leute
haben bekannt gegeben, dass sie jetzt mit Microsoft zusammenarbeiten
und End-to-End Verschlüsselungen in Skype
einbauen, was ich eigentlich ziemlich cool finde.
Finde ich witzig, dass Skype
jetzt vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder cool wird.
Es war früher mal cool, weil es halt der eine
große Anbieter war, der direkt irgendwo
Videochat konnte, Sprachchat
und Videochatten. Es lief
und es lief gut vor allem. Man hat es aber nie wirklich zum
Chatten benutzt, man hat es immer nicht direkt für Videokonferenzen
verwendet. Ich habe Skype,
es gibt Leute, die nutzen Skype sehr aktiv,
Chat-Client. Ich war persönlich nicht Teil dieser Gruppe.
Wenn der Skype benutzt hat, dann
eigentlich nur zum Anrufen. Ich habe einmal mit
Skype Pizza bestellt, was ich super cool fand.
Einfach viel bessere Audioqualität war als
Telefon. Ach du, weil du damit
normal telefonieren kannst? Genau, ich habe auch immer noch,
glaube ich mittlerweile so zehn Jahre, habe ich so
zehn Euro an Skype-Credits, die immer wieder
auslaufen und wo ich dann eine SMS an mich
selber schicke und das geht ganz,
ganz, ganz
aber dann war es, also das
Coole an Skype früher war ja, dass es komplett
Peer-to-Peer lief. Das haben sie ja mittlerweile
Genau. Und das Komische war halt, also das Schwierige war halt, dass die da so ein Konzept hatten, wo es gewisse Superpeers gab, die dann auch für andere Leute mitgetunnelt haben. Und das konntest du halt nicht so gut ins Mobile übertragen, weil du kannst Mobilgeräte nicht zum Superpeer machen.
weil zum einen hat das eine sehr hakelige Verbindung zum Internet
und zum anderen hast du da Akku- und Akku-Probleme
und da klappt das halt nicht mehr so gut.
Aber deswegen hat Microsoft, als sie es gekauft haben,
ja komplett wieder zentralisiert,
nicht so schön dezentral, wie es vorher lief
und den Client halt immer weiter gefühlt gegen die Wand gefahren.
Also Skype ist schon seit mittlerweile sehr langer Zeit
klein, technisch totaler Schrott
und nutze ich überhaupt nicht mehr.
Aber es ist witzig, dass die jetzt da
wieder cool aufhandsuchen und was
Schicks machen. Ja, ich bin mal gespannt,
was sich daraus jetzt entwickelt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich
jemals wieder Skype verwenden werde, aber
es gibt zum Thema,
also Skype ist auch ein bisschen erwähnt worden,
das war natürlich
bevor diese Nachricht rauskam,
in einer Folge von
Changelog, und zwar Folge 279,
die ich vorgestern gehört habe.
Die ist aber schon ein bisschen älter, oder?
Die ist vom 15. Dezember tatsächlich.
An dieser schönen Empfehlung,
weil wir das das letzte Mal vielleicht noch nicht
erzählt haben, ist es ein Interview mit
Alan
Durek,
einem der Mitarbeiter von Wire.
Der hat auch an Skype mitgearbeitet.
Er hat auch an Skype mitgearbeitet
und er redet auch ein bisschen über WhatsApp, Telegram und
Signal hier. Das ist mal so ein schöner Überblick
über die unterschiedlichen Messenger von jemandem, der
tatsächlich daran mitarbeitet. Also ich kann dieser Folge
ChangeLogs empfehlen. Ich betone das in die
in die Shownotes. Aber in dem
Zuge, als diese Nachricht rauskam, habe ich mal mit ein paar
Kollegen nochmal drüber geredet. Signal
macht ja, macht
jetzt mit Microsoft zusammen Skype besser.
Die gehen ja rum, ja, WhatsApp hat das auch.
Und dann haben wir mal so ein bisschen geguckt. Eigentlich ist es nicht nur
WhatsApp, sondern Googles
Allo.
Also die benutzen angeblich das
Axolotl-Verfahren
und WhatsApp-Messenger
auch, wenn man da die Krypto anmacht.
Facebook-Messenger?
Facebook-Messenger auf jeden Fall.
Facebook mechnerst du dich überhaupt nicht mehr.
Gar nicht.
Facebook ist eigentlich tot.
Für mich sowas von.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie dann Leute nutzen.
Facebook ist so ein bisschen...
Kennst du diese Geschichte?
Das Universum wird ja immer größer und schneller größer.
Und irgendwann ist der Punkt erreicht,
da alle anderen Galaxien
sich so schnell von uns entfernen
und so weit von uns weg sind,
dass quasi...
Das haben wir jetzt schon.
Dass du nichts mehr siehst, dass das Universum schwarz ist, weil alle anderen Sterne oder alle anderen Galaxien zumindest siehst so weit mit einer Geschwindigkeit, die relativ schnell als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit von uns entfernt und in ein paar Milliarden Jahren sehen wir vielleicht überhaupt keine anderen Galaxien mehr da draußen.
So in etwa fühlt sich Facebook an.
Ich mache Facebook auf, theoretisch habe ich Schulfreunde oder Leute aus den USA, mit denen ich auf Facebook befreundet bin und ich sehe aber eigentlich von denen fast nichts.
Ich sehe irgendwelche komischen Veranstaltungen,
ich sehe irgendwelche Werbungen,
ich pflege ja auch meine Filterpilase
auf Facebook nicht so neulich,
aber ich sehe nur noch vielleicht zwei, drei Leute
und tatsächliche Freunde,
mit denen ich eventuell über Facebook Kontakt halten möchte,
mit denen ich nicht mehr in der gleichen Stadt wohne
und die ich jahrelang nicht gesehen habe,
von denen bekomme ich eigentlich auf Facebook fast nichts mehr mit.
Und die Aussage von Zuckerberg war jetzt,
wir würden gerne die Timeline wieder ein bisschen tweaken,
dass du weniger von irgendwelchen Medienhäusern
mitbekommst und mehr von deinen eigentlichen
Freunden, weil Leute ja offenbar mit ihren Freunden
kommunizieren wollen und nicht
sich Fake News von
irgendwelchen Verlagen auf Facebook
ziehen wollen. Das ist natürlich
spannend. Also ich glaube, es ist
ein ganzes Stück zu spät.
Wie wollen die damit Geld machen? Das geht doch
quasi gegen alles, wofür die eigentlich stehen.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach so ein bisschen
eine Schamoffensive,
dass sie ein bisschen ihren Ruf wiederherstellen wollen
als soziales Netzwerk und nicht als
filtergebabbeltes
Nachrichtenportal.
Nutzt du Facebook im Alltag?
Bist du da öfter mal?
Also das Allereinzige, wofür ich es benutze,
ist Veranstaltungen
in Dresden. Da sehe ich manchmal,
weil andere Leute das offenbar noch dafür benutzen,
sehe ich ab und zu in meiner Timeline,
der oder die interessiert sich für dieses und jenes Konzert
und dann kriege ich ab und zu nochmal mit, dass demnächst
Cat Car in Dresden spielt.
Und dann ist Facebook
für mich manchmal noch nützlich, aber
mehr als einmal die Woche höchstens,
aller allerhöchstens schaue ich eigentlich nicht rein.
Ich bin komplett gekickt vor
mehr als einem Jahr mittlerweile und gehe da
nicht hin, never, never ever.
Das eine, was mich richtig nervt, ist, dass
die lokalen Cocoa-Heads, also
die Epileptiker
slash iOS und
macOS und andere App-Plattform-Entwickler,
die Meetups werden oftmals
über Facebook besprochen, wann die
sind, wo die sind, aber
immerhin geht am Ende immer noch über meetup.com
irgendwann einen Link raus. Das ist halt das
dass man für Meetup zahlen muss.
Beschissen in Anführungsstrichen. Irgendwann muss das halt die Kosten
tragen und aktuell macht das bei uns halt keine Firma,
sondern soweit ich weiß, läuft das über
Privatpersonen und das ist halt kacke
und deswegen sehe ich auch ein, dass man Meetup nicht
mitmütten mag. Das Schöne an dem
Geschäftsmodell von Meetup ist, dass du zahlst.
Wie meinst du mit ich?
Naja, der Benutzer zahlt,
meine ich.
Also ich als Meetup-Besucher zahle nicht.
Nee, klar, aber jemand als Betreiber
eines Meetups muss zahlen.
Das ist eigentlich ein schönes Geschäftsmodell, wenn du mal so drüber nach
denkst, weil da bist du der Kunde und nicht
das Produkt. Ja, im Prinzip, ich bin ein großer Freund davon
für Dinge, die man nutzt und
die, wo man auch sicherstellen möchte, dass
der Service dahinter auch weiterlebt, dass man
dafür Geld hinlegt. Zum Beispiel für meinen
E-Mail-Betreiber zahle ich,
weil ich zum einen sicher gehen möchte,
dass ich nicht das Produkt bin und zum anderen möchte
ich sicher gehen, dass ich nicht der
Hoster bin, weil ich mir nicht,
also ich würde es wahrscheinlich hinkriegen, aber
ich traue mir nicht sicher zu mit 100%
Garantie, die man natürlich ja
auch nicht gibt, aber natürlich bedeutend
besser als was ich machen könnte, mir selber meine E-Mail hostet.
Und wenn ich da mal was verkacke, dann
E-Mail ist mir wichtig genug, dass ich da gerne
Ich habe ja auch irgendwann
mal selber E-Mails gehostet und das mache
ich nicht mehr. Hast du noch
andere Vorträge vom Kongress mitbekommen?
Wenn wir da nochmal zurückgehen.
Es gab einen sehr schönen Vortrag
Are all BSDs created
equally? War das der, der gesucht hat
nach BSD-Renorabilities? Genau.
Ach, das war toll. Der war spaßig.
Der war auf jeden Fall schön. Also der hat geredet über
ich habe hier mal
ich beschäftige mich mit Kerneln und
greife die an und suche nach irgendwelchen
Schwachstellen und BSD ist ja sowas,
wo alle denken, naja, es ist einigermaßen
verwandt. Und der hat dann
allerdings im Laufe dieses Vortrags relativ schön
dargestellt, die sind an vielen Stellen
sind sie auseinandergelaufen. Einige BSDs
haben eine bessere Code-Qualität, weil die sehr viel
Legacy-Code weggeschmissen haben. Andere haben
schlechtere Code-Qualität. Die komplett ihren Bluetooth-Stack
einfach gelöscht haben, weil sie ihn scheiße fanden.
Ja, genau. Ich glaube...
Was ist das für BSD oder Open?
Open BSD hatte die beste Code-Qualität
und...
Die haben auch den kleinsten
die kleinste
Code-Base und am wenigsten
Legacy-Code. Und eine Vermutung
war auch noch, naja, wenn die einen irgendwie was fixen
und richtig machen, dann wird das
sich ja irgendwie propagieren und du merkst
aber, dass die überhaupt nicht miteinander sprechen. Also
eine von den
Vorschlägen, die er gemacht hat, war, die Leute, die einzelnen
BSD-Meter, sollten mal miteinander reden
damit die irgendwie Sachen diese bei FreeBSD fixen,
auch bei NetBSD fixen.
Als er das gesagt hat, hat so ein Typ,
drei Plätze neben mir sehr laut aufgelacht.
Das fand ich großartig,
wenn man miteinander redet.
Ha, never gonna happen.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen schade.
Also du hörst aus der BSD-Ecke,
hörst immer,
ja, wir sind aber von der Qualität her besser als Linux.
Aber eigentlich der Vorteil von Linux ist,
dass es wesentlich, wesentlich, wesentlich mehr benutzt wird
und es wesentlich, wesentlich, wesentlich mehr Leute
dahinter stecken und daran arbeiten als an BSD.
es kann sein, dass die an manchen Ecken bessere Code-Qualität haben,
aber es ist einfach weniger maintained
und es sind weniger Leute, die versuchen, Probleme zu finden oder zu fixen.
Das hat er, glaube ich, auch angesprochen,
ob das Many-Eyes-Prinzip da wirklich zutrifft oder nicht.
Aber was ich sehr witzig fand, war am Ende seine Zusammenfassung,
wie er diese ganzen Vulnerabilities, die er gefunden hat,
was ich auch mal krass fand.
Er hat sich da einfach, glaube ich, vier, elf Monate hingesetzt
und Source-Code gelesen, quasi.
Stimmt, er hat gesagt, ich habe es einfach gelesen.
Ich habe es einfach gelesen.
Toller Typ. Unglaublich cool.
wirklich für vier Monate lang zäh lesen
in meiner Freizeit, da würde ich glaube ich eingehen bei
Amund. Also du bist gespoilt mit
anderen Programmiersprachen. Ja, bestimmt.
Aber ich finde, ein toller Typ,
das mal dahingestellt, aber zu einer Zusammenfassung fand ich
großartig toll, wie er diese Vulnerabilities
gemeldet hat und was die Reaktion drauf war.
Ja stimmt, bei manchen hieß es dann,
bei manchen kam keine Antwort, bei manchen kam
oh ja, das fixen wir
und dann hat er eine Antwort bekommen, woraus ja
vorging, dass er innerhalb von einer Woche, einem Tag
Die einen haben es quasi über Nacht
alles gefixt, aber nie halt released.
Das war NetBSD, glaube ich.
Da hat er gesagt, Hut ab, das haben sie
echt mal schnell und gründlich gemacht,
aber es ist nie upstream gegangen.
Ich habe seitdem nicht mehr von denen gehört.
Bei den anderen hat es irgendwie zwei, drei Wochen gedauert.
Der Hauptmitglied, der Urlaub
war, den wir entschuldigt hatten, das alles gefixt hat
und die meisten Sachen sind schon
drin, released auch mit.
Aber es ist halt sehr, sehr unterschiedlich, wie die damit umgehen.
Also schaut euch diesen Talk nochmal an, der ist sehr empfehlenswert
für hier.
nochmal ein Spaß-Talk, den ich mir
auch immer mitgebe, weil ich das große Klasse finde.
Das heißt, ich hatte bisher zweimal die Gelegenheit dazu.
Hacker-Jeopardy.
Oh ja.
Das war toll.
Ich ärgere mich im Nachhinein immer,
dass ich mich nicht getraut habe, vorzugehen.
Aber nächstes Jahr
nehmen wir als akronomisierbar.
Aber übernächstes Jahr, vermutlich.
Wenn ihr Bock auf Hacker-Jeopardy habt,
von Second Way gab es die Ansage, wir müssen
Kategorien einschicken. Ich werde mich
hinsetzen und mir Kategorien einfach...
Du kannst aber nicht als Teilnehmer mehr. Stimmt.
Scheiße. Also eigentlich müssten wir mal ein
akronomisierbarer Team machen. Fände ich witzig.
Ich will unbedingt...
Ich habe ja bei Datenspuren schon
zweimal an dem Hackers Jeopardy teilgenommen.
Ich habe, glaube ich, sogar einmal eine Tasse gewonnen.
Also, da hätte ich Bock drauf.
Stefan hat ja...
Ich kenne seinen Nick nicht.
Was, Stefan?
Ich muss jetzt Stefan sagen. Sorry, Stefan. Falls du das
ich kenne den Nick nicht, der beim
Hacker-Jepardy mitgespielt hat, hat ja
hart abgeräumt, also in den
zwei Runden, die er gespielt hat, die erste Runde
und dann im Final nochmal, war das Brett
quasi nur in seiner Farbe.
Das war, ja, also
war schon teilweise recht beeindruckend, schnell
beantwortet, also zum Beispiel bei der einen
Latech-Matte im Kopf setzen
und ausrechnen,
war da, ich habe auch kurz gerechnet gehabt, ja,
Integral von Mies und Endlich-Besendlich von Neffen
und so, der Junge haut er auf den Knopf, was ist eins?
What?
Ich war gerade noch dabei, also ich habe es gerade noch gesetzt bekommen, aber nicht ausgerechnet.
Das fand ich, das war schon beeindruckend.
Das hat es auch gut angegeben die ganze Zeit, aber es war schon echt beeindruckend.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Ja, wenn du so führst, dann musst du auch ein bisschen das raushängen lassen.
Das hat er gut.
Ein anderer Krypto-Vortrag, der noch ganz interessant war, war Modern Key Distribution with Claim Chain.
Was ist Claim Chain?
Das ist quasi, wie machen wir
Web of Trust und
Key Distribution für Public-Private-Key
Infrastrukturen mit Blockchains.
Was an und für sich sinnvoll ist.
Interessant.
Immer wenn ich das höre, ich weiß,
mein Bullshit-Bingo geht dann direkt im Kopf auf.
Aber ich brauche dann
einen Moment, bevor ich mir denken kann,
ah ja, vielleicht ist doch was dran, erklär mal bitte weiter.
Sonst habe ich so einen riesigen Bullshit-Stempel im Kopf,
Hast du von Kodak-Coin gehört?
Warte, fuck, Kodak, die Kameramacher haben...
Deren Stock ist relativ weit wieder nach oben gegangen,
als sie von Kodak One die News veröffentlicht haben.
Die ist in den ICO gemacht oder was?
Und ich habe es ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich verstanden,
aber Kodak bietet jetzt eine eigene Cryptocurrency
für Photographers an.
Was?
Wir packen es mal in die Show Notes,
ich habe es mir nicht durchgelesen,
aber ich fand es,
wo, wenn bei euch auch schon
das Bullshit-Bingo-Pling
macht im Kopf,
wenn ihr Blockchain hört, dann
schaut euch doch mal bitte Kodak One
die Blockchain-Cryptocurrency
von Kodak an.
Was tun die?
Okay, nee.
Es gibt so oder so noch sehr viele tolle Congress-Talks.
Ich habe mir eine Liste gemacht, die ich noch schauen möchte.
Die sind noch sehr viele Unabgehakte dabei.
Mal schauen, wie ich das
noch hinkriege.
Ich hatte mir letztes Jahr mal kurz gedacht, nee, dieses Jahr gehe ich mal nicht
auf den Kongress. Dieses Mal bleibe ich mal zu Hause und gucke mal
die Videos. Und dann kam halt
raus, dass es in Leipzig ist. Und das ist ja eigentlich einigermaßen
bei mir um die Ecke. Und ich habe gedacht,
na, bevor ich doch hin. Und
ja, als wir dort waren, waren wir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Gehen sie nächstes Jahr wieder zurück nach Hamburg. Aber ich habe jetzt
von ein paar Leuten in den Kommentaren gehört, dass die
jetzt, oder irgendwo anders sind,
dass die jetzt auf absehbare Zeit erstmal in Leipzig bleiben.
Finde ich aber auch sinnvoll. Also erstmal,
man hat jetzt einmal das Ganze organisiert
in Leipzig. Man weiß, wie es in Leipzig funktioniert.
Was in Leipzig nicht funktioniert.
was natürlich nicht funktioniert. Das ist auch
dann halt verhandlungsbare Sache wieder für das nächste
Jahr, ob man da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Freiheiten rauskriegt.
Das ist auch immer das erste Mal, sich an dem Spiel
zu hübschen. Mehr Freiheiten, um Sachen hinzukriegen,
die dieses Jahr nicht funktioniert haben, wäre,
dass du die Durchgänge zwischen den Hallen
größer machst.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen, andere Baustellen,
die noch offen waren. Also ein paar Sachen, die wirklich nicht, vielleicht haben wir das
auch bei der letzten Folge schon mal kurz erwähnt, aber die uns
dort vor Ort schon aufgefallen ist. Es ist
ein Messegelände und ein Messegelände ist nicht darauf
ausgelegt, dass plötzlich so eine
komplette Halle
evakuiert wird, nicht evakuiert, aber gelehrt wird.
Der Wort laut den Wüter dessen Folge.
Das hast du aber recht.
Ich war erkältet und ich musste dann immer
unten rum, außen nach außen
aus dem Kairaus und das war ein bisschen blöd.
Also das könnte man vielleicht noch ein bisschen...
Das rausschicken da.
Genau, wenn ihr noch coole Talk-Empfehlungen habt, dann sagt uns mal
Bescheid. Schickt uns was, wenn ihr meint,
ihr habt was Cooles geschaut.
Aber wenn wir gerade eben schon
so bei Fuck-Ups waren,
da ist doch noch was Tolles passiert jetzt vor kurzem.
so vor einer Woche circa, bei NPM.
Und was ist das?
Also was passiert ist, in kurzer Zusammenfassung,
ist, dass NPM wohl in großen Anführungsstrichen ausversehen
einen Nutzer gelöscht hat.
Und zwar ist es passiert, dass jemand,
also NPM hat wohl Dinge in place,
um Spam zu, Package, die Spam sind, zu filtern,
wenn sie submitted werden, wenn sie gepublished werden.
Und irgendwer hat ein Package gepublished mit Spammy Content,
ich weiß zwar nicht, was genau heißt, dass es Spam ist,
die meinen, die ziehen da irgendwie die Readme in Betracht
und irgendwelchen anderen Content,
aber ich weiß nicht, aufgrund von welchen Tatsachen
man ein Package als Spam erklärt, aber das haben wir dahingestellt.
Und die Readme von diesem Package
war identisch zu einem anderen Package,
was schon gepublished war. Und deren tolles System
hat dann gesagt, ey, das eine hier ist Spam
und das andere ist eindeutig
von demselben Typen.
Die hängen irgendwie zusammen, das muss auch mit gelöscht werden,
wurde auch als Spam geflaggt. Und ein NPR-Mitarbeiter,
der anscheinend diese Queue durchgegangen ist,
hat einfach prompt beide gelöscht.
Und diesen anderen Account einfach mal aus Versehen entfernt,
inklusive aller 100 noch was gepublishten Packages in diesem Account.
Das war händisch.
So wie ich das vorhin in dem Postmortem gelesen habe, war das händisch.
Und angeblich ist es ihnen selber 60 Sekunden später schon wieder aufgefallen.
Was aber plötzlich ganz viel CI rot wurde.
Also bei dem Account waren wohl Packages, die sehr verbreitet waren.
Die irgendwo natürlich in der MPM-Welt, die sonst wo Subdependencies im Ebene 70 bei anderen Packages mit drin hängen.
Das ist ja in der Notewelt nichts Neues.
Und das hat wohl sehr viel schiefgegangen.
Und die haben dann halt auch daran gearbeitet,
die händisch wieder reinzuholen, zurückzuholen,
quasi die Flags in der Datenbank wieder zu ändern,
dass die halt nicht mehr gelöscht sind.
Das Witzige war aber vor allem,
dass Leute das mitbekommen hatten,
dass die Packages weg waren
und es direkt ausgenutzt haben
und Packages mit denselben Namen
und anderen Content neu gepublisht haben.
Wie zum Teufel kann sowas
möglich sein?
Auf Hacker News wurde dann auch diskutiert,
weil in dem ersten Blogpost hatten sie geschrieben,
das wurde alles
noch ein bisschen erschwert, weil wohlmeinende
Participants
versucht haben, die gelöschten Pakete einfach
selber wieder zu publishen.
Was ja geht, ich meine, jeder hat eine Kopie davon und wenn du siehst,
oh, es ist nicht mehr auf npm.js,
dann pushe ich es einfach selber mal hoch.
Was
dass das überhaupt geht.
Aber wenn sie offenbar den kompletten Nutzer gelöscht haben,
dann konnten sie auch nicht feststellen, dass sie das jemals gehabt haben.
Wahrscheinlich der Mechanismus hat dann gesagt,
oh, das ist komplett neu.
Die muss ja bloß eine Datenmacht, die vielleicht wieder zurücksetzen,
dass es gelöscht war, haben sie gesagt.
Also die konnten schon noch sehen, dass alles da war.
Aber deren System, dass das einfach das hinnimmt.
Vor allem, dass du Packages,
also die haben ja schon mal
diese Left-Pad-Geschichte gehabt,
wo jemand selber seine Packages gelöscht hat
und damit ein Riesenproblem
verursacht hat, weil das Package halt auch hat,
benutzt wurde, überall mit drin.
Und damals haben sie halt dann die Möglichkeit
genommen, dass man,
nachdem ein Package 24 Stunden gepublished
wurde, das löschen darf. Die ersten 24 Stunden
darf man es auch löschen, selbst. Aber
nach den ersten 24 Stunden ist es quasi
für immer da. Und man muss halt, wenn man
es entfernt haben möchte,
den NPM-Support anschreiben und dann
von einem Menschen das bearbeiten lassen,
der das dann in den meisten
Fällen einfach deprecated. Was ich dann davon mal ausgehe,
das ist ähnlich wie bei Cargo,
wenn ein gejanktes Paket ist, dass es halt noch
gelistet ist, aber du kannst nicht mehr drauf dependen
oder so, sondern nur die, die schon bereits
drauf dependen. Du kannst es nur noch runterladen,
wenn es bereits in deiner Log-Datei steht.
Kann ich die eigentlich per Hand bearbeiten?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Also, ich meine,
andererseits kannst du dem
Package-Manager oder der Registry
auch nicht beweisen, dass du es schon mal
länger schon dran hast. Du könntest zumindest für Packages,
die auch in der Registry liegen, sagen, hey, da ist schon mal
die Cargo-Tummel gepostet worden.
Das auf jeden Fall, aber wenn das
wenn er es zum ersten Mal in die Log-File schreibt,
dann sagt er dir,
das ist gejankt. Ist ja auch valide.
Also okay, wenn man es umgehen kann, meinetwegen,
wenn man handlich die Log-File umschreibt, das macht
ja keiner, das wäre ja doof, aber
du kannst das natürlich
machen, aber da musst du schon bedeutend, sagen wir mal,
Gewalt reinstecken. Du musst es schon
aktiv was selber bewusst falsch machen.
Genau, also du kannst dich einfach so was
falsch machen. Aber zumindest hat der NPM, wie gesagt, damals
diese Möglichkeit genommen, dass man selber Packages löschen
darf, was ich auch absolut richtig finde.
Du bist ja auch irgendwo eine gewisse
Reproducibility haben,
du dich darauf dependen kannst, dass ein Package
vorhanden ist, wenn das einmal vorhanden war und nicht einfach morgen dann
weg ist und dein Projekt nicht mehr bauen kannst.
Was auch so ein riesiger Clusterfuck an sich ist,
dass man überhaupt heute Software
entwickelt, die darauf dependet, dass das
im Internet irgendwo Daten liegen
und die mit dem Bildprozess reingezogen werden.
Und bauen heißt ja auch
jedes Mal, das wird
jedes Mal getriggert, wenn irgendwo ein CI-Bild
losläuft und
wenn du deine Seite neu deploys,
nicht nur dann, aber
Wir haben bei uns mal ausgerechnet, was passiert, wenn wir ein Hauptrepo bauen.
Dann geht in der CI für einen Buildjob, den ich als einzelner Entwickler trigger,
gehen für N Targets, also mehrere Linux-Distributionen,
ein paar Mac-Konfigurationen, Debug und Release und Windows,
Debug und Release und noch ein paar andere Test-Konfigurationen,
geht einzelne Buildjobs los.
Und bei denen läuft dann jedes Mal am Anfang für diverse Unterprojekte, die auch nochmal Package-Daisons enthalten, dann so ein Install-Step los. Und das sind dann mehrere hundert Install-Steps mit wahrscheinlich dann halt mehreren zig Unterpaketen eventuell, die dann erstmal auf unsere interne Registry schlagen.
Ah, okay, das ist schon mal gut.
Jede Firma, die sowas hat, hat erstmal eine interne Registry, sollte eine interne Registry haben und das erstmal selber spiegeln.
Und die hat allerdings damit auch schon C zu tun.
Das skaliert natürlich schon ganz schön breit, weil du das um mehrere Faktoren multiplizierst.
Also ein Buildjob baut mehrere Targets und ein Target enthält schon mehrere Unterpakete und diese Unterpakete haben eventuell redundant die gleichen Pakete oder unterschiedliche Pakete sind immer wieder runterladen.
du dost quasi deine eigene Registry
mit jedem einzelnen Bildschirm.
Aber nochmal zurück zu NPM.
Und zwar, das Hauptproblem war ja auch,
dass Leute, die mit dem ganzen Problem
eigentlich nichts zu tun hatten,
dann versucht haben, wohlmeinend,
eigene Pakete, diese
Feder benutzen wollten, selber wieder
zu publishen, was natürlich ein Riesenproblem ist,
dass sie es eigentlich nicht machen dürften.
Du müsstest eigentlich erwarten, dass ein Package irgendwie
verschwindet aus der Registry.
Dass das für immer geblacklich ist, der Name. Für fucking immer.
Fucking immer.
Aber ich meine, NPM hat ja schon länger ein Problem,
zumindest prominent ein Problem.
Andere Packages-Männer haben das ja teilweise auch,
aber NPM hat ja sehr prominent ein Problem mit Leuten,
die halt Packages publishen, die zum Beispiel deine N-Fars
alle irgendwo hinschicken zu irgendeinem Service.
Ich meine, die haben fünf Stunden gebraucht, um das zu fixen.
Das ist erstmal nicht schlecht, das beeindruckt schnell,
respondet, nur ein bisschen traurig,
dass es überhaupt so sowas gekommen ist.
Vor allem, dass das Spam-System halt Pakete von einem anderen User
einfach flaggt. Das ist eindeutig broken, das System.
Ja, das ist einfach so ein innertes Problem von NPM,
dass es aus was erwachsen ist,
was eine kleine Convenience für drei Entwickler hätte sein sollen
und dann zu so einem großen Infrastruktur-Backbone
für einen Riesenteil der Entwickler-Community geworden ist.
Das stimmt.
Wo es eigentlich andere Paketmanager gibt,
die dafür viel eher geeignet gewesen wären als NPM selber.
Und jetzt ist es halt so, dass alle NPM und auch das NPM-Backend nutzen
und dann immer mal wieder solche Sachen passieren.
Ich muss schon echt Spaß sein, so zu arbeiten.
Das ist ja zumindest abenteuerlich.
Aber so ein paar Sachen in diesem
Postmortem
von dem Issue, von der Sache,
stören mich echt ein bisschen. Zum Beispiel,
dass sie halt oben sagen, dass
das ja gar kein Security Issue ist, sondern
Operations Issue. Hallo?
Geht's noch? Leute haben
Packages gepublished
unter demselben Namen, die
fremde Bildprozesse einfach mit reingezogen haben
und da war...
Das ist ein generelles Security Issue an und für sich,
weil die Pakete ja auch nicht wirklich signiert sind.
Man hat halt kein Trust-System
in NPM überhaupt.
Eigentlich bräuchte man eine Blockchain für Vergebung.
Wo kommt jetzt da die Blockchain her?
Nee, Trust bei
Dependency-Managern ist echt was,
was man...
Oh, gut für die Shownotes.
Da hatte der Vincent erst einen Link rumgeschickt.
Der Vincent von HelloSwift?
HalloSwift, ja.
HalloVincent.
Das war aus dem
Rust-Diskurs. Das war ein Link
von, ich dachte immer, der heißt Man is Earth
aber anscheinend ist er Maniche Earth oder so?
Ja, das mit dem Earth habe ich auch noch nicht verstanden,
aber Maniche ist auch einer von den relativ influentialen Entwicklern
in der Rust-Community.
Der hatte auf internals.rustline.org in dem Diskurs einen Post gepostet
mit dem Titel Solving Great Trust, wo er sehr ausführlich darauf eingeht,
was Pansuma angehen müsste
und wie man possibly
Trust-Issues
lösen könnte
oder zumindest einen guten Anlass dafür gelöst.
Da können wir in Zukunft
irgendwann mal drauf eingehen. Wir packen mal den Link auf jeden Fall
mit in die Show Notes rein. Da kann ich gleich noch eine andere
Podcast-Empfehlung machen. Es gibt ja diesen
Podcast The Manifest, den ich vielleicht
auch schon oder den wir vielleicht schon ein, zwei Mal erwähnt haben,
wo es eigentlich nur um Paketmanager geht die ganze
Zeit. Also fast wie akronomisierbar,
bloß nicht auf Deutsch.
Und da gab es eine Folge
und zwar
war das Folge 7,
The Update Framework. Und da ging es auch
darum, wie man Trust in
Packetmanagern vorbeiführt.
Ich muss meine Aussage
von vorhin repetieren.
Es gibt welche, die
ziehen das sehr wohl schon in Betracht. Gerade
nehme ich an die Folge mit Maven da zum Beispiel.
Die machen schon sehr, sehr viel, was das angeht.
Aber es ist nicht
sehr weit verbreitet in der Dependencymanager-Welt,
Trust-Issues mit anzugehen.
Ja, also wenn
so eine Linux-Distro jemand angreift,
dann wartet und es kommt
Chartcode in ein signiertes Paket, dann hast du
entweder dein
GPG-System erfolgreich
angegriffen oder jemand hat
bewusst aus dieser
Gruppe der auserwählten
Maintainer
dann hat einer von
diesen Leuten was veröffentlicht, aber
dass irgendjemand irgendwas
nach npm.js schiebt, ist
ein ganz anderes Kaliber.
Oh Mann, npm.
Immer wieder witzig.
die Notwendigkeit.
Wir machen das ein bisschen jetzt so eine eigene
Kategorie, diese Woche in NPL
Fuck-Ups. Nee, das ist gemein.
Also die machen ja auch schon einen echt
guten Job, das muss man denen ja auch hingeben.
Die arbeiten auf einer massiven Scale
und die stellen schon ein echt solides
Projekt hin, aber es kommt halt
immer wieder was Witziges bei rum und das ist halt
auch immer wieder traurig, aber ich meine, es ist auch
nicht falsch, wenn solche
Fuck-Ups, ich nenne die jetzt
liebevoll Fuck-Ups, also nicht Fuck-Ups von
You guys fucked up, sondern
bei euch etwas Witziges passiert.
Das ist ja schön, wenn sowas passiert,
damit auch andere Package-Manager
oder Dependency-Manager eben drauf sehen können,
oh, sowas kann tatsächlich passieren,
vielleicht sollten wir sowas auch direkt
mit einplanen und
solche Probleme mit
betrachten zumindest und nicht, oh, wenn es
passiert, dann schauen wir drauf, sondern
lass uns gleich von Anfang an
mit einbeziehen.
Ja, aber trotzdem merkt man doch,
gerade wenn man sich The Manifest anhört,
Das ist übrigens ein Podcast, bei dem ich erst relativ spät gemerkt habe, dass es zwei Moderatoren sind.
Das habe ich letztens auch gemeint.
Die klingen exakt identisch dabei.
Da merkt man doch auch, dass viele Features, die sinnvoll bei dem einen Paketmanager sind,
bei dem anderen gar nicht in Frage kommen.
Also die scheinen, genauso wie die BSD-Distros, nicht wirklich dolle vom anderen abzugucken.
Also man merkt, wenn man sich Jahren anguckt, das ist ja bloß ein Client,
die haben bei sich auf der Startseite geschrieben, Prior Art,
Und dann zitieren sie andere Paketmanager, an denen sie sich orientiert haben.
Aber Features, die in Maven drin sind, die nicht in NPM drin sind,
das müsste eigentlich nicht sein, weil NPM irgendwie zehn Jahre später erfunden wurde.
Prinzipiell kann man auch da viel miteinander reden und kommunizieren.
Das ist halt immer das Problem, wenige Leute, die JavaScript schreiben,
sind halt irgendwo in der Java-Welt angesiedelt auch mit oder waren es mal
und haben Maven genutzt und wissen, wie das System läuft
und was es da so für Bitfalls gibt.
Die Leute gehen halt selten wissenschaftlich vor.
Man sagt nicht, okay, ich erfinde jetzt mal sowas
und ich schaue mal, was gab es denn schon
und was machen die denn und worauf muss ich denn so achten,
sondern die meisten hacken halt
erstmal drauf los und haben dann noch ein paar Tagen
was läuft und denken sich so, ich habe jetzt eigentlich
alles bedacht. Und so macht man halt die gleichen
Fehler immer und immer wieder.
Ja.
Hast du übrigens gesehen, dass es ein neues Sourceforge gibt?
Ja. Ich finde es witzig, dass sie
jetzt einen kompletten neuen Relaunch machen,
weil ihr Image ist ja immer noch im Keller.
Das Image von SourceForge ist so ziemlich im Arsch.
Wie war das?
Die haben vor ein paar Jahren,
wurde SourceForge verkauft an jemanden,
der das zum massiven Malware-Schleuder gemacht hat.
Und das ist von wieder auch ein paar Jahre her,
dass es dann wieder verkauft wurde,
an jemanden, der versucht, das Projekt seitdem zu retten.
Und aber mit dem Image nicht klarkommt,
was diese Malware-Schleuder-Leute halt damit gemacht haben.
Also das ist mir auch persönlich auf die Füße gefallen,
muss ich sagen.
Ich habe selber nie mit SourceForge
auf die Art und Weise gearbeitet, dass ich da selber
Code verwaltet habe mit.
Allerdings war das die Quelle,
wo ich zum Beispiel immer FileZilla runtergeladen habe.
Und wenn ich dann Leuten, zum Beispiel
Mitbewohnern von mir, damit wir im Haus uns mal
ein bisschen was in Musik hin und her schieben können,
dann erzählt habe, dann installiere ich nochmal
FileZilla und hier gehe ich einfach auf
sf.net slash FileZilla
und ziehe dir das runter und plötzlich
kriegen die dann irgendwelche
Tools bei was installiert und dann denke ich mir,
wie kann das sein? Und dann merkst du erstmal,
ah fuck. Also das Problem
SourceForge war mal sowas, was GitHub heute
ist, allerdings nicht so schick
und mit SVN.
So kann man es beschreiben.
Was es allerdings
wesentlich mehr macht, was GitHub
glaube ich nicht so richtig macht, ist,
dass du dort einfach deinen Installer
auch hostest. Ja, du kannst ja mit GitHub
Releases mit Binaries vollspicken.
Ich sehe das aber nicht. Das sehe ich
sehr, sehr oft.
Aber was für mich den SourceForge Unterschied gemacht hat, ist,
dass SourceForge dir noch direkt
die Möglichkeit gegeben hat, auch dynamischen
konntest du aus, du konntest dein Supportforum mit
auf SourceForge schmeißen und solche Dinge,
was GitHub halt überhaupt nicht macht.
Was auch vielleicht gar nicht mal so falsch ist, dass GitHub das nicht macht,
aber das war halt toll an SourceForge und dafür haben es
auch viele Leute genutzt und das finde ich auch
immer noch ein gutes Feature, dass es nicht wahr war.
So,
wir gehen ein paar Jahre in die Zukunft, kein Mensch
mehr vertraut SourceForge, weil SourceForge ganz
viel Malware und eigentlich
Adware ausgeliefert hat, das heißt, die haben
von den Installern von Open Source Projekten
nachträglich die Installern von Open Source
Projekt gepatcht, damit die Werbung mit
installieren, was super, super
eklig ist.
Und jetzt gab es vor ein paar
Tagen eine Anmeldung
oder eine Bekantgabe
Introducing the new Sourceforge
und diese
Webseite sieht auch komplett neu aus, das heißt
sie sieht vielleicht komplett neu aus, ich war ein paar Jahre
auf der Seite.
Und ich lese auf
Hackern News auch immer wieder, die machen schon lange,
also die arbeiten schon lange dran, keine Malware
zu publishen oder Malware Adware
rein to patchen und sonst wie.
Aber man traut der Plattform halt einfach
nicht mehr.
Nee, also es ist eigentlich ein verbranntes Ding.
Aber ist doch schön, wenn sie daran festhalten, dass wir
behalten wollen.
Oh, we've also created a GitHub
Importer Tool that will import
your GitHub Project to SourceForge
and sync your GitHub Project file release
releases
on SourceForge so you can
take advantage of the strength of both
Plattforms. Witzig.
Okay, was hilft mir das,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel was bei SourceForge hause?
Ich habe ähnlich wie du nie
meine Projekte gehostet.
Gibt es dafür irgendeinen Grund?
Fühlt es sich mehr nach einer
Produktseite an, wo ein fetter Download-Button
hier ist? Ja, also die Charakteristik
von SourceForge gegenüber GitHub war schon immer mehr,
dass es versteckst, dass du dort deine
Software entwickelst, sondern eher eine Plattform
bietet, um deine Software dort zu vermarkten und zu
verteilen und
ein Frontend für den Kunden
deiner Software anzubieten
als ein
für die Entwickler deiner Software.
Und das wollen wir auch weiterhin
in den Vordergrund stellen.
Warum nicht einfach den Namen wegschmeißen
und eine andere Domain kaufen? Keine Ahnung.
Ach so, es furcht gehört Slashdot?
Da können wir eigentlich
jetzt bei der Gelegenheit können wir mal so ein bisschen
Internetarchäologie
betreiben. Was gibt es denn noch? Gibt es noch Slashdot?
Klar gibt es noch Slashdot.
Gehst du manchmal auf Slashdot? Ich dachte, Slashdot ist
komplett
Slashdot dachte ich eigentlich,
dass es komplett von Hacker News verdrängt worden ist.
Ich war das letzte Mal vor Jahren auf Slashdot, aber ich war auch nie wirklich aktiver Slashdot.
Was ich bei Slashdot aber mal schön fand, ist, dass die für die Topics so witzige Icons hatten.
Das heißt zum Beispiel, wenn ein Artikel über Microsoft war, hast du so einen gephotoshoppten Bill Gates als Borg als IKG.
Gehen wir mal ein bisschen weiter. Was passiert denn, wenn ich AOL.com eingebe?
Dann lande ich auf, und das gibt es noch, AOL.com.
Ob die Domain ausläuft, das kann es bestimmt nicht.
Das ist natürlich das Erste, was ich sehe, ist so ein
fettes Bild von Trump.
Von wem wurden die gekauft?
Howell wurde gekauft?
Nee, aber das war Yahoo.
Yahoo.com wurde von irgendeiner Firma gekauft,
die keinem Menschen was gesagt hat,
aber sie gibt es jetzt noch weiterhin.
Allgemein diese Portalseiten.
Schau mal, es gibt noch Ask.com.
Das war die Suchmaschine, die ich als erstes benutzt habe,
bis ich Google entdeckt habe.
Ob es Alta Vista noch gibt?
Alter, bist du leider noch wie Yahoo, Alter.
Die allererste Suchmaschine,
die ich verwendet habe, war Fireball.
Hast du von denen jemals gehört?
Nope, sagt mich nicht.
Fireball, das weiß ich auch bloß,
weil es dafür Fernsehwerbung gab.
Fireball.de, gibt es immer noch.
Das sieht aus wie Wolfram Alpha.
Schickt uns mal ein paar Beispiele für
hornalte Webseiten, von denen man nicht
dachte, dass es sie noch gibt und die eigentlich noch da sind.
Oder generell, weil was
für euch so die Anfangszeit des Internet war.
Ich hatte mal eine Seite auf Geocities,
aber die gibt es ja wirklich nicht mehr.
Es gab irgendeine deutsche Variante
von Geocities, wo ich mal was gehostet hatte.
Das war glaube ich
Fortune City. Und das war dann
fortunecity.de und du hast dich da angemeldet
und dann hast du
zwei Unterordner
bekommen. Du hast dann
das erste nach dem Slash war ein Straßenname,
ein zufälliger. Und das
danach war eine Hausnummer.
Ich war bei Fortune City, irgendeine
Lane
35 und da war dann meine Webseite
gehostet. Oh, finde ich cool. Das Internet
ist schön veranschaulichend.
Und da hast du dann statischen HTML-Content
hochgeladen und die haben dir Werbung reingepatcht.
Das heißt, in meiner Seite
sind dann auch die Werbebanner aufgetaucht,
die sie auch wieder reingepastet haben.
Das fand ich super.
Ich erinnere mich an Hosting bei
Ohost oder so.
Oder Funpick.
Vielleicht bringe ich auch völlig den Namen gerade durcheinander.
Das war irgend so ein Host, wo du ein bisschen Webspace bekommen hast
und du hast Zugang zu einem C-Panel gehabt
und für mich war das so,
oh mein Gott, ich bin jetzt Web-Admin.
Das ist ein kompletter Bullshit.
Oh Mann.
Nee, lass mal raus aus der
historischen Internet-Schiene.
Wo wir gerade so schön bei Fuck-Ups waren, eine Sache, die gerade
vorhin noch passiert ist, finde ich einfach super witzig.
Man hat ja dieses
Emergency Alert-System über SMS
ist so eine verbreitetes
Methode, um Emergency Alerts zu verschicken.
Das gibt es bei uns aber nicht, oder?
Ich meine, das gibt es auch im nicht-US-amerikanischen Raum, aber vielleicht auch nicht.
Also kurze Zusammenfassung, in den USA kann dir die Regierung SMS auf dein Telefon schicken,
um dich über irgendwelche Notstände zu informieren.
Die werden halt von vielen modernen Betrieben, mobilen Betriebssystemen auch direkt als Emergency Alerts gehighlighted
und nicht einfach als eine SMS von einer unbekannten Nummer oder so.
Und das gleiche gilt für Radio- und Fernsehsender, wo die diese Emergency Services einmal in der Woche dann auch so eine Testmeldung machen.
Also bei uns, wenn du hier durch die Stadt gehst, hast du einmal in der Woche oder einmal im Monat.
am ersten Mittwoch jeden Monat, glaube ich,
auf 5. Uhr hast du dann von der Feuerwehr
so eine laute Lautsprecherdurchsage
und in den USA kriegst du
das halt aufs Handy direkt geschickt.
Ich bin auch ganz froh, dass wir das bei uns nicht aufs Handy
geschickt kriegen. Wir haben aber auch weniger
Naturkatastrophen.
Wir haben nicht so viel Waldbrände, wir haben nicht so viel
Erdbeben und Hurricanes.
Das nicht, aber im Prinzip ist das System
nicht falsch. Wir werden selten mit Atomwaffen bedroht.
Großer Tag. Was ist denn hier bei dir
nur passiert? Die hatten auf
Hawaii vorhin so einen witzigen Inzident,
wo jeder Hawaianer oder jeder, der sich aktuell
in Hawaii befunden hat,
zu einem Emergency-Lot-Attend bekommen hat, wo es schon in All-Cap stand
Ballistic Missile Threat inbound
to Hawaii. Seek immediate shelter.
This is not a drill.
Und alle erst mal voll die Panik geschoben.
Bis es dann kurz
darauf rauskam. Oh fuck, das war ein Ausversicht.
Was heißt denn hier voll die Panik geschoben? Gab es da irgendwie
Leute, die sich dann irgendwie vergraben haben?
Oder Herzanfälle hatten?
Also du wirst wahrscheinlich morgen mehr zu wissen.
Das ist jetzt noch relativ aktuell.
O-M-F-G.
Hey Siri, what time is it in Hawaii?
The time in Honolulu, Hawaii,
the United States is 10.35.
Da wissen wir es, das war vor
zwei Stunden aktuell.
10.35, bei uns ist es jetzt übrigens
21.35, das heißt,
die sind uns doch elf Stunden,
ja doch.
Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es nur elf Stunden sind.
Das heißt ja, dass es von der Ostküste bis nach Hawaii bis drei Stunden
Unterschied macht. Zwei.
Drei. Zwei.
Zwei, noch weniger.
Ich meine, Zeitzonen sind jetzt nicht einfach nur so 100 Meter.
Das ist schon...
Also ich meine, Zeitzonen-Grenzen sind auch recht arbiträr irgendwo gesetzt, aber...
Ja, aber Hawaii ist mitten im Pazifischen Ozean.
Das ist schon ein ganzes Stück weg von der Westküste.
Trotzdem super witzig und der Post wurde erweitert seit vorhin, wo wir das gelesen haben.
Auch der Screenshot hier ist schon neu.
Das finde ich schön.
Sie sollten jetzt mal langsam wieder einen Anfang finden.
Wollen wir jetzt weiter darüber reden?
Nee, nee.
War einfach ein witziger weiterer Fuckup.
Einen anderen Fuckup haben wir aber noch.
Möchtest du mir was zu Intel erzählen?
Oh ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und zwar wurden jetzt in den letzten Wochen
zwei Attacken bekannt gegeben,
die natürlich innerhalb von wenigen Stunden
auch wunderschöne Icons hatten.
Das findet man alles.
Ein guter Angriff braucht einen guten Namen.
Genau, das machst du nicht gut.
Und das sind zwei Vulnerabilities,
die mehrere Angriffsvektoren zulassen.
Einer ist gefährlicher, der andere ist weiter verwendbar.
Der eine heißt Meltdown und der andere heißt Spectre.
Ich bin an der Stelle kein großer Betriebssystem-Experte
oder Kernel-Experte oder Prozessor-Experte an der Stelle,
was es angeht.
Vielleicht wisst ihr darüber auch bereits schon mehr als wir.
Allerdings handelt es sich hierbei um grundlegende Design-Probleme
moderner Architekturen,
moderner Prozessorarchitekturen, was heißt moderner
Prozessorarchitekturen, alle
Prozessorarchitekturen seit etwa
1995, die so
spekulative Ausführungen unterstützen,
um damit die Performance zu erhöhen. Und zwar, was die
machen, ist, dass die Cache innerhalb
des Prozessors spekulativ
schon mal auffüllen,
selbst wenn
der Speicher, auf den du zugreifen möchtest, von dir
als Benutzerprozess gar nicht
zugegriffen werden kann und das erlaubt
dann über Zugriffszeiten
festzustellen, welcher Speicher in diesen Cache geladen wurde
und dadurch entweder als unprivilegierter Benutzerprozess
Kernelspeicher auszulesen
oder im Fall von Spectre
von anderen Prozessen Speicher auszulesen.
Die genauen Papers, die das beschreiben,
waren eine ganze Weile unter Embargo.
Die Fehler sind schon vor einigen Monaten
von unterschiedlichen Gruppen festgestellt.
Im Juni 2016.
Bitte?
Und Intel hat gesagt,
bitte wartet damit mal noch eine Runde,
damit wir das auch fixen können,
bevor ihr das bekannt gebt.
Das Problem ist, wenn du so ein Paper schreibst,
musst du natürlich auch ein Proof of Concept dazutun.
Und den Proof of Concept kannst du natürlich
ohne weiter relativ schnell
für tatsächliche Angriffe verwenden.
Deswegen soll das möglichst schon gefixt sein,
sobald du diese Veröffentlichung wirklich public machst.
Das Problem ist,
Intel kann da nicht viel fixen, also ein bisschen was haben die wohl gemacht an Mitigation, aber vor allem müssen das, bei der Sache kann Intel da halt nur durch neue Chips nachbessern, durch neue Chips designen.
Also ein paar Sachen können sie, die Mitigations sehen so aus, du kannst eine relativ weite Palette von Chips durch Microcode-Patches fixen, dass zum Beispiel Caches regelmäßig gelöscht werden, wenn du in den Kernel eintrittst.
oder indem du, es gibt zum Beispiel auch Fixes für Compiler, die dann Code ausspucken, der diese spekulative Ausführung in die Irre leitet und dementsprechend.
Es gibt da eine wunderschöne Zusammenfassung, wenn ihr fließend Englisch versteht, eine Folge aktuell tun wir in die Shownotes.
Cast, da haben sie den
Herrn Godbolt, der
diesen Compiler Explorer aufbaut,
einfach mal eine Stunde zum Thema Meltdown
und Spectre reden lassen. Das war sehr
aufschlussreichend, ich musste mir auch, glaube ich, zweimal anhören,
bis ich es vollständig verstanden habe.
Die tatsächlichen Angriffe
sind allerdings nicht wirklich so schwerwiegend
wie die Konsequenzen, die dadurch
eintreten, dass man die
Systeme dagegen härtet.
Es wird nämlich, je nachdem,
welchen Fix auf welcher Plattform
man vornimmt,
wird davon ausgegangen, dass zwischen 2 und 30 Prozent CPU-Performance dabei auf der Strecke bleiben.
Das heißt, unsere Systeme werden, gerade sehr viele Cloud-Systeme, viele Cloud-Anbieter haben natürlich Angst,
dass Leute, die in ihrer Cloud Code ausführen, aus den Hypervisoren ausbrechen können und deswegen alles patchen.
Und diese Systeme werden alle massiv langsamer werden.
das muss hart ins Geld gehen.
Das war so richtig, gerade bei Amazon
oder bei Microsoft Azure oder
bei Google Cloud-Dingens da.
Eigentlich bei jedem Webservice.
Aber gerade der finanzielle Aspekt muss da,
das wird schon spaßig.
Also gibt es jetzt auch schon eine kleine Action-Lossout
gegen Intel, habe ich gesehen.
Da wurde wohl schon irgendwas aufgefahren, aber das...
Aua.
Aber für mich das
schönste Detail an dieser ganzen Meltdown-Spector-Geschichte,
also Meltdown betrifft ja
in erster Linie erstmal nur die Intel-Prozession,
Spectre ja quasi alle, mehr oder weniger.
Fast alle, ja.
Es gibt immer mal vereinzelte Berichte,
dass Raspberry Pis nicht betroffen sind.
Die haben das so stolz. Die haben auch eine echt gute
Zusammenfassung in dem Blog geschrieben von
Spectre und am Ende so stolz, ja, wir sind
davon nicht betroffen, ja, das heißt aber, dass ihr einfach
scheiß Technik verbaut. War vorher schon so langsam.
Aber
das netteste Detail an der ganzen
Geschichte ist, dass
die
initialen Findings im Juni
letzten Jahres waren.
das Embargo lief wohl bis aktuell
deswegen kommt das jetzt alles so ein bisschen raus
aber im November
2017 hat der CEO
von Intel erstmal alle seine
Aktien, die er legal verkaufen durfte, verkauft
das kann doch
einfach nicht sein, oder?
Also wenn das passiert, dann weißt du, dass irgendwas
massiv im Argen ist. Aber das ist doch sowas von
Insider-Trading, wie kann das
also jemand, der Typ ist doch sicher auch
kein Vollidiot, entweder
ist der einfach nur total bekloppt, sowas zu tun
oder ist sich unglaublich sicher, damit
durchzukommen. Aber
wie kann das sein?
Da gab es auf dem Commit-Strip ein schönes Bild,
einen schönen Comic dazu. Können wir auch noch in die Shoutouts tun.
Da sieht man im letzten Panel den
Intel-CEO auf einem kleinen
Kutter voller Goldbahnen und
Geld. Und sie sagt dann
I swear I sold my stock options in November.
It was just because
I wanted to buy this yard.
Oh man.
Ja, eine der schlimmen Sachen daran ist auch, dass wir jetzt auf absehbarer Zeit erstmal damit leben müssen,
dass diese Mitigations unsere Computer alle langsamer machen.
Selbst wenn es nur 2% sind, sind es halt 2%, aber jedes Mal, wenn du I.O. machst, wirst du langsamer zum Beispiel,
weil du dabei in den Kernel eintrittst.
Die Browser sind auch ein Stück langsamer geworden.
Einfix, der in Firefox
kam, war, dass sie einfach mal
die Granularität von ihren Benchmarking-Tools
runtergesetzt
haben. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt
nur noch auf 20
Millisekunden genau oder Mikrosekunden genau,
zumindest ein ganzes Stück weniger genau,
Zeiten messen,
wenn du deinen JavaScript-Code
benchmarkst. Und das war, weil auch
darüber ein Angriff möglich war.
Da gab es übrigens auch noch einen Talk
auf dem Kongress, den können wir noch in die Show-Notes ziehen.
Ich habe allerdings selber immer noch nicht geguckt,
deswegen kann ich da jetzt nicht viel zu erzählen.
Empfehle ich bloß mal, weil mir der empfohlen wurde.
Genau, und das Problem ist,
dass wir jetzt, wie gesagt, auf absehbare Zeit
erstmal damit leben müssen und so wie
Prozessoren entwickelt werden und
wie lange es dauert, so ein
Werk für CPUs
umzustellen, um die nächste Generation tatsächlich
herzustellen, kann es sein, dass wir die ersten
CPUs und alle anderen Chips, die davon
nicht mehr betroffen sind, wahrscheinlich erst
so ein paar Jahre. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und bis, keine Ahnung, dann Geräte
Dingern verbaut tatsächlich verkauft werden.
Es ist auch mal ein bisschen on top.
Es ist fast ein schöner Opel-Moment.
Am zweiten ersten, wo das Ding announced wurde,
wo du so in die Runde schauen konntest,
ja, und wer ist betroffen? Du bist betroffen! Und du bist betroffen!
Und du bist betroffen! Und du bist alle
betroffen! Everybody gets a car!
Was?
Ach, nee. Es ist schön zumindest,
dass die großen Hersteller wirklich alle gefixed haben.
Microsoft hat ja jetzt Patches rausgeschoben.
Apple hat das aktuelle High Sierra wohl schon
im Dezember gefixt gehabt, die Idee mit dem Update.
iOS-Geräte kam jetzt ein Update,
das zumindest gegen die Browser-Vulnerabilities
mit abschließt.
Aber was ich auch schön fand,
die Linux-Maintainer,
die ja auch schon
unter vorgehaltener Hand quasi die Fixes da
in den letzten Monaten gearbeitet haben,
haben die Vulnerability,
bevor der Name Meltdown jetzt halt populär war,
intern immer Forcefully Unmapped Complete
Kernel with Interrupt Trampolines genannt,
aka Fuckwit,
weil die immer so angepisst waren von diesem Scheiß-
Ich finde das gut, dass die alle
gebrandet werden.
Das ist toll.
Es gab auch so ein schönes Ranking von Internet
auf Twitter und zwar
Heartbleed, whoops, the internet is burning,
Shellshock, oh no, Bash is
broken, sorry.
Und dann Meltdown und Spectre,
we had a nuclear reactor accident 20 years ago
and just found out,
yeah, good luck.
Ich mag dieses Branding, du kannst ja keine CVE-Nummern
umherwerfen, da weiß ja niemand, von was du sprichst.
Apropos die VI-Nummern,
das war auch so eine witzige Sache, das war
direkt am 1.1., da hat
jemand ein macOS Zero Day
einfach rausgehauen. Oh shit.
Der hat da was gefunden in diesem
IO-HID-Family
Framework, glaube ich, das ist da für
alles, was so Human-Interface-Kram
ist, also so Trackpad,
Kamera, Display-Kram,
Tastatur, da fließt da alles mit rein.
Und da hat er irgendwelche Unabilities gefunden,
Details habe ich jetzt auch nicht mehr im Kopf, könnt ihr mal raussuchen.
aber was ich halt witzig fand, ist, der hat die am
1.1. rausgehauen,
auf Twitter einen Tweet geschrieben mit
Fuck it, I'm releasing a zero day.
Okay. Ich hab das eigentlich gelesen, ja.
Schön, krass.
Aber man munkelt, das hat er nur getan,
weil das CVE-System
auch so ein bisschen gameable ist,
wenn du nämlich, wenn die halt
ja und du durchnummerieren
chronologisch in dem Jahr und er wollte halt
2018 01 haben.
Und deswegen ist das schön
in der quasi Holiday-Zeit
noch ein Zero-Day gedroppt.
Das ist halt auch nicht so schön.
Das ist natürlich auch schön für die Leute, die es dann fixen müssen
und vielleicht so die erste Woche im Januar
noch im Urlaub sind, die sich auch gedacht haben,
du Drecksack.
Aber das ist auch blöd von Apple. Es gibt halt auch kein
Bug-Bounty-Programm für MacOS. Apple hat ein Bug-Bounty-Programm
für iOS, aber nicht für MacOS.
Und selbst das iOS-Bug-Bounty ist
Invite-Only. Apple versteht nicht,
wie Bug-Bounty-Programme funktionieren.
Ja, so ein Bug-Bounty-Programm
bräuchten wir hierbei akronomisierbar eigentlich auch.
Machen Gefühle?
Ihr könnt uns ja
jederzeit immer gerne, wir freuen uns,
wenn ihr uns über Twitter oder andere Kanäle
schreibt, was wir für Stuss
erzählt haben oder besser konkret
welchen Stuss wir erzählt haben, dann würden
wir uns auch bereit erklären,
einen Rater am Anfang der nächsten
Sendung zu machen dazu. Besonders gerne,
wenn jemand sich besser
zum Meltdown auskennt als
wir und darüber in Deutsch reden möchte.
Ich habe nämlich bis jetzt nur
englischsprachige Podcasts dazu gehört.
Dann würden wir auch gerne mal wieder eine Interview-Folge dazu machen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wollen wir mit euch, mit dir quatschen?
Auch du könntest zu Gast bei Akronomie Silber sein.
Sag mal bei Podcasts und bei Audiosachen eigentlich auch so,
dass man die vierte Wand durchbricht.
Geht das?
Das mache ich eh die ganze Zeit.
Nee, das gibt keine, wir haben ja eigentlich keine vierte Wand.
Also wir sprechen ja direkt mit den Hörern.
Wir reden ja, genau.
Weil wir gerade mit dem das eben nicht getan haben.
Aber wir sprechen direkt mit dir, mit euch.
Genau.
Gut, am Ende der Sendung kommt nochmal unsere beliebte Sektion, andere würden es Picks nennen, wir nennen es den GitHub-Star der Woche, Sachen, die wir auf GitHub geil fanden und einfach weiterempfehlen würden. Kean, fang doch mal an.
Ich habe ein cooles Projekt entdeckt von Jonas Kolb namens Beak. Beak ist eine Art Make in Swift.
Macht aber den coolen Ansatz, dass du einfach quasi ein Swift-Script schreibst und Beak automatisch die Public-API davon analysiert und dir alle Sachen, die Public sind, direkt als Targets zur Hand gibt.
die Documentation dazu mit
rausschmeißt und so kannst du zum Beispiel dann
über Beak einfach dann diverse
Funktionen direkt aufrufen und
in Swift quasi einen
Make- oder Make-Ersatz schreiben. Das finde ich ziemlich schick,
aber kannst du einfach mal daneben legen.
Das braucht man in Swift, weil es da sowas noch nicht richtig gibt?
Es gibt diverse, es gibt einwitziges Projekt,
das heißt Sake statt Make-Sake,
also Swift-Make,
aber das finde ich nicht so schön.
Beak macht das tatsächlich sehr schick, einfach über die
Public-API-Auto direkt ansprechen.
Finde ich einen netten Ansatz.
hat es schön gelöst. Ist schick.
Super schick. Und nutzt intern auch
coole Libraries, wie zum Beispiel
die Utility Library aus dem
Package Manager, die vor kurzem gepublischt wurde,
wo viele Dinge drin sind, wie ein Argument Parser,
der einfach recht schön ist.
Finde ich ein tolles Projekt. Sehr schön.
Eine Familie an Projekten, die ich empfehlen würde,
sind
Bloaty McBloatface.
Ich liebe dieses Namenskonzept
so sehr. Bloaty McBloatface
und eine Inkarnation davon Cargo
Bloat. Das ist ein Tool,
was deine, ja, aber Bloaty Mac
Bloatface ist quasi der Vorläufer gewesen,
der ist quasi
ein Tool, was
deine Binarys scannt und dir
anzeigt, welche Code-Sektionen am
meisten Platz verwenden. Das funktioniert, wenn man
das über Cargo Bloat
macht mit Rust Binary, ist eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Du baust quasi
deine Library oder deine Binary Release
und der zeigt dir zum Schluss an, welche
Funktionen oder welche Code-Sektionen am
meisten
deinen Binary-Code produziert haben.
Und das hat, als es rauskam,
war das am Anfang noch gar nicht für Libraries selber,
sondern es ging nur für Binaries.
Ich habe dann ein bisschen mitgelesen in den Issues,
war dann allerdings relativ schnell auch für Libraries
möglich, das rauszubringen. Und die schönste Folge war,
dass der Maintainer von Clab,
diesem Command-Line-Argument-Parser,
in Rust gemeint hat, oh, ich habe damit mal rumgespielt
und ich habe schon
relativ schnell was gefunden, wie ich den Speicherverbrauch
von Binaries, die Clab verwenden,
um bis zu 300 KB
runterkriege.
Gerade Clapp produziert ja eine ganze Menge Code.
Clapp, wie gesagt, du schreibst dann
für das Tool, was ich gebaut habe,
schreibst dann halt 200 Zeilen Funktionsaufruf hin,
die einfach bloß deinen Kommandozeilen-Parser konfigurieren.
Und das hat er dann auf,
und das wird in vielen Binarys verwendet,
zum Beispiel in RipGrab.
Und er hat gemeint,
ja, ich habe das dann mal auf RipGrab geworfen,
die neueste Version,
das hat 300 KB Speicher verwendet.
Und da ist die Binary von 4,5 MB
auf 4,2 Megabyte. Das ist doch toll.
Genau.
Wahrscheinlich ziemlich dicke Binary, aber
ist ja auch ein dickes Ding.
Ist gar nicht mal so. Haben wir schon mal über Binary Sizes
geredet? Eigentlich ist es nicht. Ne, das sehen wir uns mal auf.
Binary Sizes ist ein tolles Thema. Genau.
Also guckt euch
Cargo Bloat an. Cool.
Was ich noch habe, ist ein Projekt
vom Helge. Ich weiß nicht, ob Helge
diesen Podcast hört. Falls ja, hi Helge.
Der hat auf jeden Fall die letzte
Folge live zumindest mir angehört.
Unsere Kombi-Folge.
unsere Synergie-Folge. Stimmt, wir waren live.
Wir waren live, wir hatten einen Stream.
Holy shit. Nee, aber das Projekt von ihm,
was ich sehr, sehr cool finde, er hat ja schon mal
ein ähnliches gehabt, das kann ich gleich am Ende nochmal ganz schön ansprechen,
das, was jetzt hier ist, ist PLSwift,
heißt das ganze Ding. Das ist ein Tool,
mit dem, oder
du kannst damit
Funktionen und Types in Postgres
direkt in Swift schreiben. Und du kannst ja
Postgres erweitern um Funktionen und Types
und da kannst du
jetzt nicht nur Kram in
sonst was schreiben, sondern direkt
in Swift Dinge an Postgres randocken.
Ich hätte nicht erwartet, dass sowas möglich ist.
Ich finde es total
faszinierend, dass ich damit Swift-Code
in meinen Postgres mit reinschieben kann
und das vom Postgres ausgeführt wird
und somit quasi
Dinge in die Datenbank-Ebene reinschieben,
die dort einfach viel besser und effizienter
ausgeführt werden können, als wenn ich sie in mein
Backend schiebe,
was halt das Frontend zu meiner Datenbank
quasi ist. Also wie er schön hier schreibt,
bringing Swift to the back end of the back end's
back end. Finde ich schön.
Er hat schon mal was ähnliches gemacht,
das heißt ModSwift, wo man Apache Modules
in Swift schreiben kann, finde ich auch total faszinierend.
Die letzten Mal rumgespielt.
Ein Apache Modul ist ja einfach bloß eine
Shared Library, die ein bestimmtes Interface anbietet.
Also eine C-API.
Ja, das ist natürlich schön, wenn man das plötzlich
in höheren Sprachen, in sichereren
Sprachen machen kann vor allem.
Ja, cool.
Ich habe noch zwei kleine Sachen. Das eine ist wirklich
sehr klein, ein kleines
Add-on für Visual Studio Code
und zwar Bracket Pair.
Das highlightet einfach Bracket-Pairs farbig.
Das heißt, wenn du drei ineinander geschachtelte Gruppen von runden Klammern hast,
dann haben die unterschiedliche Farben, sodass du optisch sehr gut zuordnen kannst,
wenn Klammerpaare, welche Klammerpaare zusammenhören.
Und vor allem, wenn du Klammern hast, die keinen Partner haben, werden die knallrot.
Das sieht man auch ziemlich schön.
Das hat leider ein Problem.
Ich schreibe ja in Sprachen, wo auch spitze Klammern vorkommen.
Und das hat es von Haus aus nicht unterstützt.
beziehungsweise ist unter den Default-Klammerpaaren nicht dabei.
Und ich habe es dann mal einfach in die Config reingehackt
und es ist sofort umgefallen, weil es nicht damit klarkommt,
dass in der Syntax auch Pfeile mit schließenden spitzen Klammern vorkommen.
Und da geht natürlich einiges kaputt.
Das ist leider sehr schade.
Also ich habe auch mal reingeguckt,
da ist ein Issue schon seit ein paar Wochen oder Monaten offen.
Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich so bald auch nicht gefixt.
Aber trotzdem, wenn man davon absieht,
ist es eigentlich ganz nett, wenn man Farben mag.
Das ist zum Beispiel in Sprachen,
wo du Custom-Operatoren mit einzelnen Klammern
haben kannst, geht das dann daran auch
kaputt? Oh Gott, gibt es echt?
Du kannst doch Custom-Operatoren definieren
wie lustig, bis man halt keine Klammerpaar
passt. Das würde ich jetzt gerne mal von dir
gezeigt bekommen, dass man
eine offene, runde Klammer als Custom-Operator
haben kann.
Lass uns jetzt nicht drüber reden.
Ein weiteres kleines
Mini-Projekt, was wahrscheinlich
noch kaum jemand benutzt, ist
WikiTranslate.
Danke.
Okay, dann möchtest du uns dazu was sagen?
Wir hatten tatsächlich schon,
das hätte ich nicht erwartet, dass wir das bringen,
tatsächlich vor ein paar Folgen,
glaube ich, mal drüber gesprochen.
Wir hatten, glaube ich, schon vor ein paar Jahren mal
im ASCII drüber geredet, dass man ja eigentlich
die beste Übersetzung findet nicht in einem Wörterbuch
für Wörter, die Ambiguities haben,
sondern über Wikipedia.
Was zum Geier ist dieses Ding
auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch?
Und dann sucht man sich das auf Wikipedia raus
und sucht sich dann einfach...
Über die Selbstversicherungsleiste deiner Seite den englischen Artikel.
Ich hatte letztens wieder, ich suchte tatsächlich
die englische Übersetzung für das deutsche Wort
Lab, also das, woraus man Käse macht,
weil ich keine Ahnung hatte, was das
englische Begriff dazu ist. Und das findest
du in dem Wörterbuch halt einfach nur so Laboratory
und Abkürzung Lab und alles mögliche
und du weißt halt nicht... Schreibt sich das auch L-A-B?
Schreibt sich L-A-B, Lab.
Und ich hab da halt nicht direkt was gefunden,
vor allem, weil das englische Wort halt mir völlig unbekannt ist
und es ist halt nicht rausgesprungen in der Liste von
anderen Begriffen. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich den Wikipedia-Artikel
zu Käse gelesen.
Aber Lab hat halt einen eigenen Artikel
und hat den englischen Counterpart unter dem Titel Renit.
Renit sagte mir nichts, aber gut zu wissen,
dass das der passende Begriff dazu ist.
Und dann habe ich jetzt mal eine kleine CLI in Zwift geschrieben,
die genau das tut.
Du sagst einfach, welche Sprache ist deine Suchsprache,
gib mir einen Begriff und dann sagt er dir,
welche Liste von Artikeln, ist da der Gesuchte dabei?
Sagst du, ja, der da.
Und dann gibt er dir alle Übersetzungen, die es dazu gibt,
aus den verlinkten Artikeln direkt raus.
Das finde ich super schick.
Und ich habe gesehen, du hast gleich direkt danach
dasselbe nochmal geschrieben,
mit exakt meinem Text aus der Readme geklaut.
Es wurde nicht als Spam markiert,
obwohl es fast die gleiche Readme war.
Push mal auf NPM.
Ich kann es ja mal auf Cargo pushen.
Ich habe mir gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee
und ich hatte dich gefragt, ob das auf Linux läuft,
was du da hast und du hast mir keine Antwort geben können.
Ich habe gesagt, keine Ahnung, probier mal aus.
Ja, ich hatte an dem Abend dann keine Lust mehr,
das Swift-Setup dann auf meinem Linux-Laptop
nochmal zu installieren.
Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
es gibt ja so ein Wikipedia-Crate.
ach, dann baue ich das einfach mal fix selber.
Und im Endeffekt läuft das darauf hinaus,
dass ich selber, um das zu bauen,
vielleicht 20 Zeilen Rust in der
Library schreiben musste und
allerdings wahrscheinlich nochmal anderthalb bis zwei Stunden
in diesem Wikipedia-Crate rumgewühlen
musste, was eine sehr Rust-untypische
API hat. Die Wikipedia-API
ist aber auch an sich ein Monster, also die zu
rappen ist nicht schick. Ich habe mich da auch von der Weile
mal aus dem anderen gesetzt, als ich diese Idee halt machen wollte.
Ich habe letztendlich zufällig auch nochmal ein
Zwift-Paket gefunden, was das unerschöne Wegwebt
und der hat auch eine tolle Readme, wo er die
Interaktionsmöglichkeit beschreibt und damit
hat das prima geklappt und dann war ich glücklich.
Aber dieses Wikipedia-Crate
dachte ich mir, gut okay, da ist die Funktionalität,
die ich jetzt dafür brauche, noch nicht drin, das patch ich mal
selber rein, aber dass das so ein
Knotencode ist und der
Sachen macht, wo du dir denkst,
so kann man das nicht einfach machen.
Der benutzt zum Beispiel
Serda zum Deserialisieren von Jason
und das geht jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weiter,
aber der benutzt Serda zum Deserialisieren von Jason
und deserialisiert aber nicht in irgendein
Custom-Typ, der diese gleiche Struktur hat,
sodass man dann einfach auf die Properties
davon zugreifen muss, sondern die Serie wird immer nach
JSON-Object und dann geht er dann immer,
baut immer so eine Kette auf, gib mir das als Objekt,
dann gib mir das erste davon, also der
macht das wirklich alles von Hand
und das macht es mich ein bisschen eklig und du hast eine
API, wo du, wenn du Strings übergibst,
zum Beispiel für Namen, musst du geownte
Strings reingeben und keine
String-Literale, was du eigentlich
normalerweise machst, das heißt, du musst dann jedes Mal erst
einen String erzeugen, dem du denen dann schenkst, das ist
komisch. Aber okay, sei dahingestellt,
es läuft erstmal ganz gut.
finde ich trotzdem cool.
Ja, es gibt das 2-Informationen von
Wikitranslate, super cool.
Wir können ja mal
gegeneinander benchmarken.
Ich wette, dass du gewonnen hast,
weil einerseits...
Ich muss 3 Web-Requests machen,
ich vermute deine Wikipedia-Creative
macht das mit 2,
weil die Sprachenfetschen
nochmal ein Request braucht.
Wenn das der Fall ist, dann hast du
so oder so schon gewonnen.
Keine Ahnung, ich mache wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche.
Genau, fällt uns noch was ein ansonsten?
Ich nehme übrigens gerade zurück,
was ich mit offenen Klammern für
Operatoren gesagt habe.
Ich kann zumindest in Swift natürlich nicht
runde Klammern oder geschwungene Klammern für Operatoren nutzen.
Andererseits gibt es natürlich schrängend spitze Klammern als Operatoren.
Sowieso schon.
Gut, den Shift-Operator, den gibt es halt.
Oder halt kleiner als.
Shifting kleiner oder die Pfeile, das ist halt so oder so schwierig.
Stimmt, wenn es das gibt, dann müsste es ja eigentlich
auch runde Klammern geben, so Soft-Shifting.
Mir ist bloß gerade aufgefallen, dass
die
runde Klammer so ein bisschen wie das Swift-Logo
ausschaut.
Geschwungene Klammer nach rechts, meine ich.
Das könnte der Swift-Operator sein.
Der Swift-Operator.
Okay, jetzt geht es mir auch zu weit.
Wir werden ja jetzt eh mit unseren Pics quasi durch.
Genau.
Wenn ihr Vorschläge für coole
Gitterpics habt, dann schickt uns die doch bitte mal.
Ich würde sagen, damit hätte es sich.
Ja, damit hetze ich es mit Folge 13.
Akronomisierbar, Folge 13.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr bis jetzt zugehört habt.
Wir wünschen euch noch einen wunderschönen
Tag,
Tag, Abend,
Nacht,
Spaziergang,
Putztag.
Ach, sorry, einmal will ich noch einwerfen.
Hast du diesen Tweet gesehen von wegen?
Oh my God, I asked Google Home
how long was left on my timer
and it gave me the average life expectancy
for women in the United States.
Oh, herrlich.
Sorry. Ja, lass die Folge zum Ausklang finden.
Ich glaube, das schneide ich an den Anfang.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei geblieben seid.
Das war Folge 13 Akronomisierbar.
Wir hören uns hoffentlich bald wieder.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurem Catcher beginnt in 3, 2, 1...